you just don't know when to give up
doing this all day
I could do this all day yes all day is
this the end of Captain America and
Chris Evans wow that's that's that's not
really up to me you know I mean it's I
have I have Avengers three and four and
in the contracts up so I mean you know
if we'll see what happens that's you
know unfortunates a long time away
Avengers three doesn't come out till
next year and then four doesn't come out
till 2019 so I mean if they were gonna
continue it would it wouldn't be for
quite some time and like I said that's
that's not my call hey everybody it's
Charlie I could do this all day so Chris
Evans did this really big interview and
everybody's been asking me to do a video
for it because he implies that when his
contract is up he's gonna stop playing
Captain America he might leave I'll
explain what he actually said because he
certainly implies that he might be
leaving but that doesn't really tell you
what might be happening to the actual
character during these movies so there's
two things that are going on here
there's the concept of Chris Evans
future in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in the future of the Captain America
character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and I haven't seen a lot of
people talking about it but I actually
think that he's being a little sly with
the press and with Marvel Studios
because remember even though he works
for marble he's a free agent meaning
that he's up for contract renegotiation
so when he says that he might be done
playing Captain America going forward
after Avengers 4 that means a lot of
different things so if you're finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get all the Marvel videos there is a
new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
replica giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so Captain
America what's going on with Chris Evans
and what's up with this giant super
stache that he took from Henry Cavill
seriously I think I found out what
happened to Henry cabals mustache after
he shaved it the other day like he just
posted that Instagram video I don't even
recognize myself it's like the Lich from
adventure time you keep defeating it but
somehow it keeps coming back the reason
for the stache is he's playing a police
officer and a villain during a Broadway
play after he's done with Avengers 4 so
obviously you'll see him doing
interviews for all this stuff I don't
know if he's gonna do interviews while
he has the mustache that'll be kind of
weird but as part of this big article
that the New York Times did he talked
about getting off the train before
they push you off so a lot of people are
like wait a minute he's done with
Captain America after Avengers 4 what
does that mean for the character how
many more of these the thing I actually
think is going on is that his agents as
we speak like while we're waiting for
affinity Ward to hit theaters his agents
are renegotiating his contract with
Marvel and he's using the press just a
little bit to negotiate which isn't
totally underhanded it's been done a lot
before even Studios will do it so if
you're not familiar with the idea of
negotiating in the press what'll happen
is is say like an actor needs to
renegotiate their contract or they're in
some sort of contractual dispute with a
studio one of them will go to the press
and the press will write a story that
sort of demonizes the other party so the
public like you meet everybody else
that's reading about this will take
sides
so say Chris Evans wanted to direct a
movie during Marvel phase four or phase
five or something like that
and maybe make a couple of small cameos
but Marvel didn't want to let him do
that he might let the press know that
hey you know I'm kind of thinking that I
might be done with Captain America so
the press writes a story that says Chris
Evans is done playing Captain America in
all the Captain America fans all around
the world get really pissed off at
Marvel so Chris Evans agents can use
that as leverage in their negotiations
with Marvel to get whatever it is that
they want now Chris Evans isn't an
underhanded person he's actually a
really good dude so I don't think he
would be really shaky but there's always
a level of this that goes on the big
studios will do the exact same thing
when they fight with unions like unions
try to get better terms better working
hours better money for their people so
they'll talk to the press and try to get
their side of the story out that kind of
demonizes the other party so negotiating
in the press is a very risky proposition
sometimes it can backfire depending on
how good your leverage is so what I
think Chris Evans is doing is that he's
letting people know that he is kind of
tired but the rumor that I think has a
little more credence is that he actually
does want to direct a movie down the
road because he does direct a lot of
movies he does a lot of his own material
when he's not doing these big Marvel
movies you talked a little bit about
directing but tell me a little bit about
the producing side because now you're
kind of responsible for a whole ton of
stuff well that's tricky you know this
is this is all a learning experience for
me I've never been
part of some of these discussions so he
actually genuinely does like to work
behind the camera I think what he's
trying to do is they're renegotiating
for future appearances either cameos or
flashbacks just more Chris Evans in some
form in phase four and phase five in
exchange for things like directing a
movie down the road so even though that
doesn't tell you what the future of the
Captain America character is in phase
four phase five it does let you know
that there might be more Chris Evans
Robert Downey jr. style like popping up
in other people's movies even if there's
no Captain America for they might still
pass the title of Captain America on to
Winter Soldier or Falcon or somebody
else way down the line before Avengers
five but even going back as far as age
of Ultron Chris Evans has always talked
about maybe leaving after his contract
is done like you just look at his body
language and a lot of the interviews
that he does and it's just like yeah he
definitely does not look like he wants
to keep doing this for the next ten
years so again what I think will
probably end up happening is is they
will find some terms for him to do
cameos in future films but for the most
part I don't think that he's going to
come back and they're gonna do three
more Captain America sequels they'll be
more Captain America but when we get to
Captain America for it will be another
character debuting as Captain America so
I've already done a couple videos about
how I think that Winter Soldier is the
best person to take the mantle
they've already hinted at it like look
at Sebastian Stan as far back as that
first Captain America movie how many
times have they referenced that he was
Captain America in the comics for a
little while
[Music]
they save think about how much leverage
that gives Kevin Feige like people
always try to argue from the studio side
of things that these characters are
bigger than the actors like we could put
somebody else in this title and they
would totally eat it up because they
love Marvel movies so much there are a
couple people within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that have started to
overpower their characters Robert Downey
jr. is the best example of that there
might be other people that fill his role
like Sheree is this tech wizard she does
a lot of the same things that Ironman
does but even if she climbed into a suit
of her own armor she's not going to be
the Iron Man character Robert Downey jr.
will henceforth be known as Iron Man no
matter what happens to the character in
the next couple of movies so early
speculation what happens is is that
Marvel read this New York Times article
and they told Chris Evans look as long
as you keep quiet about this while we're
negotiating we'll give you some of the
things you want they'll find some way to
negotiate for some cameos down the line
like remember the cameos he had during
spider-man homecoming just really funny
things it wasn't even him in present-day
so he got detention you screwed up he
was new footage shot if it was a
flashback and even that post credit
scene implied that he wasn't so sure if
he was gonna keep doing this
how many more of these we haven't quite
got to the point where we see a lot of
Marvel movies set during the past so I
think we see more Captain America during
phase four phase 5 it's probably no more
than you saw Iron Man
during spider-man homecoming regardless
of whether or not the character dies
during the next two Avengers films he
can always be brought back via the barf
technology there's actually supposed to
be a barf scene that we actually saw the
behind the scenes for a little while ago
the Russo brothers explained oh you know
you saw a version of that during civil
war so whatever it is that Iron Man's
doing he's using the barf technology to
look at something from the original
Avengers movie during the plot of
Avengers 4 which is why Captain America
is wearing his classic Avengers suit
spider-man Winter Soldier anybody could
hook themselves up to the barf machine
in Magic Chris Evans up and they would
have to shoot new footage for that so
Chris Evans would have to come
meaning that he would have to agree to a
new contract the narrative weight of him
dying or Ironman dying is just too good
to ignore like in order to make these
movies feel real you actually have to
experience real loss so I definitely
think that Captain America and Iron Man
are at the top of my death predictions
list so let me know in the comments
Iron Man and Captain America what do you
think is gonna happen to them after
Avengers 4 there are a whole bunch more
infinity war videos that I'm working on
leave all your requests in the comments
below and I'll say congratulations to
Manuel Abad you're the giveaway winner
from my last big video please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to rewatch the
Deadpool trailer again and click here
for my Silver Surfer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]